hey guys what's up is Daniel here from D
LM model
lifestyle where we give you the best
tips on grooming style fitness and
modeling life and I'm right here in my
model apartment in South Korea Seoul
where my next modeling contract is for
about two or three months now a lot of
you guys have been asking me Daniel
could you please give us more modeling
tips for beginners so in this video I'm
gonna give you five modeling tips for
beginners and we're starting right now
[Music]
all right so let's say hold on me just
put this down all right so let's say
you've joined a modeling agency what now
well the first and the most important
thing is to start working on your model
portfolio the model portfolio is very
very important start getting in contact
with some photographers to do some test
shoots ask your new modeling agency to
help you a bit because they have the
contacts and then you use websites like
model mayhem and those kind of website
to get in contacts with photographers to
start building in that book what you
want to do is you want to focus on a few
things you want to focus on good
headshots and you want to focus on
different facial expressions and
different outfits of clothes for example
there are different clients right there
are clients who have sport clothes and
there are clients who have business load
their clients who have watches it's all
different lines and so you want to have
a portfolio that can show them hey I can
do your product so do a few different
styles and do a few different hairstyles
and clothes and then build your book up
now you're gonna start to get some
modeling jobs as soon as you get those
modeling jobs take the brand name write
it down and search for it as soon as the
pictures are out because that's how you
build a really good book you cannot just
have tests you need to have some jobs in
there with a mix of some accessories and
that's never gonna stop as you grow in
modeling you're always gonna keep an
updated and your book is just gonna get
better and better better because you're
gonna get better but also the quality of
jobs you're gonna get is gonna be better
because your portfolio is better all
right now I said you have to contact
photographers right and you can go on
websites like model mayhem and other
websites but this brings me to tip
number two don't trust anyone in this
industry don't don't do it just just
don't there are countless stories of
people that's been mistreated even
sexual abuse it don't be naive please
I've seen a lot of people get hurt
really bad because of modeling
especially for young girls if you start
modeling you want to be a really
good modeling you want to have good jobs
and so you're very kind and a
photographers and know that and they
take advantage of you don't let it
happen also don't let a model agency
take advantage of you please don't let
that happen
okay be careful who you trust number one
do your research talk to the other
models who are with your agency and then
number three if you go for your first
photo shoots don't go alone go with
someone alright alright let's go to step
number three so let's say you have your
portfolio and now you're starting to get
some castings but it's castings well
it's huge is going to the client and
going for basically interviews right
they see you they might take some photos
they might ask even to do some poses
they will look at your model portfolio
and then they will get in contact with
your agency and say hey mmm Peter and
the nice looks like really good models
please could we book them for the 20th
or something like that thing that's how
they do it so the client will get in
contact with your agency and then they
can book you right through them they
will not contact you directly they have
a first option which means this is the
model they really would like to use but
if something would happen to this model
they have a B plan and a C plan right
sometimes they're also not 100% sure
about the model that I want a book
that's why they have the second option
the third option but don't worry and
stress too much about that just wait if
the client book you great if not that's
fine there are more opportunities all
right so how do you prepare for castings
well number one if the agency sends you
the message and say hey we have a
casting for you to see is the brand name
and then what you have to do is look the
brand name up on the internet check out
the previous photoshoots check out what
kind of models they like and so you are
prepared and you know what to expect
when you go to the casting and you have
to dress accordingly for example if the
casting is for support you'll be very
silly to go there dressed really smart
right and then if it is for smart but
you go more like very very casual expose
are not a good idea in the West it's
okay you don't dress up that much in the
East it matters a lot you need
dress up a little bit now that being
said most of the times if you wear black
clothing like this black fitted clothing
then it will be okay or I don't wear to
baggy clothes where the client cannot
see how you really look like that is for
guys and for girls girls you have to
take your high heels with you guys we're
lucky we don't need high heels now a
very important tip the casting does not
start when you introduce yourself to
decline the casting starts when you open
that door even though it's line is busy
with some other models every now and
then they would scan the room and they
will look to get some impressions I see
a lot of guys coming into the casting
and I act all tough and they come in
with walking there I mean yo what's up
and they say hello to some people and
but then when they're in front of the
client is like hi hello and it's like a
personality switch they suddenly they
are very friendly and very nice and very
kind and as soon as the casting is done
when they turn their face like hey yeah
the whole Syria isn't different right
don't be arrogant be confident in who
you are but in a humble way all right
nobody is more important than anybody
else right everybody in this world has
the same value it doesn't matter what
kind of job you do right so be confident
and not arrogant is actually my fourth
tip because models don't realize how
important a personality is if there are
five models they all look pretty in good
the clan will choose the one that they
like the most that's a very important
thing that you need to remember all
right so when you go to the casting be
humble be kind be confident in who you
are but don't be arrogant don't be
puffed up all right all right now let's
move on my fifth tip is accept that you
will be rejected all right that happens
a lot and a lot of models are very down
in the dumps if they get rejected and
life is so bad and life is too hard and
and they bring that attitude with them
to the next casting and then this client
actually likes them how they look and
they might get the job but now the
client looks at their personality and
thinks man this model looks great
perfect or she's perfect for my brand
but their personality I don't want to
work with this person I don't want to
work with somebody on set that's like
this don't let rejection bring you down
so that you miss your next opportunity
if you were declined what model would
you book right that's what you have to
think when you go to these castings so
you will be rejected I've been rejected
a lot of times and when I was younger it
really affected me you know yeah it was
it was hard but now I don't mind at all
because there's a thing things that you
have to accept number one it will happen
right because the client is looking for
a specific model he's looking for
someone with brown hair or black hair or
blonde or blue eyes or green eyes or
dark eyes or he's looking for somebody
who's very slim or he's looking for
somebody who's got broader shoulder
he already has an idea in his mind about
the model that he wants so don't feel
offended because it is not personal and
then the second thing you have to
remember is the law of averages if you
could for example to send castings and
you booked one job that's good that
means every ten castings that you will
go to you will may be booked good job
which is really good so you know okay
you go to a casting boom you do your
best right and it's done go to the next
one do your bash boom it's done go to
the next one boom you do your best right
so your personality don't change at all
you are who you are every time when you
go and see a client right but a mistake
that a lot of models do is when they
feel rejected emotionally they bring
that baggage with them to the next
casting you can't do that all right
be strong be confident do your best now
if you're serious about your modeling
career check out my modeling ebook here
where I give you a lot more tips on
modeling
alright guys those are my five tips for
today if you like the video give me a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video
you